fait jeunes 1 on est souvent lâché dans
la tête mais ça se voit quand même sur
la gueule
alors s'il ya d'accord avec vous c'est
ce que je veux dit tous les matins en
commande coccinelle chaussures fait
[Musique]
c'est
attention
[Applaudissements]
milad shirts et d'haïti c'est c'est
susan mayer dans desperate housewives
[Applaudissements]
on peut mieux faire niveau et vos
compositions en à votre avis à vous les
filles et pas nous servir un berger nom
serge est
[Musique]
non
bouksman qui veut dire l'homme chant
slam chance est d'être à vos côtés voilà
parce qu'il est chanceux des centres que
c'est le mercato lundi je me reconnais
moi j'ai pas relié pas le cinéma
lavirotte poggetti surtout pas de vie
privée
vous êtes en couple vous vivez seul vous
habitez ou une motion demandant comme un
patois sous 10 à pas nous
[Rires]
mais c'est parce que les gens veulent
savoir mais vous aime et c'est pas dire
des choses des choses me dire voilà
est-ce qu on n'est diffusé que dans le
marais où
j'aimerais évidemment qu'on aille
chercher tous les instruments de la
terre si vous aussi vous êtes devant
votre télé sortez votre instrument et
jouer
j'ai rencontré le théâtre ya pas très
longtemps et je pensais pas que je
pourrais être là tous les soirs à leur
imaginaire et ac est en fait ouais
l'envié mais on
va essayer encore là non à cinq minutes
près les limites de la délation
c'est qu'il soit là ou
non mais je disais moi j'ai des
les amish n'ont ni smartphone ni radio
ni télévision mais ils ont un journal
the budget
créée en 1890 c'est leur principale
source d'information à sa tête marcus
miller il n'est pas à mich
mais ses ancêtres l'était
[Musique]
celui là a bien marché cette semaine
l'image est étonnante voire surréaliste
dans les rayons de ce supermarché
ces femmes sont des himbas
l'une des plus anciennes tribus de
namibie
d'ordinaire elle ne quittent jamais leur
territoire
mais comme plus rien ne pousse dans les
champs le chef du village les envoyer
faire les courses pour la communauté ou
bien tu je sais pas je serai présente
mais grosso modo de bouteilles d'huile
de tournesol par un parent 0 je prends
kevin de lynne bon ben voilà on n'est
pas d'accord on va je suis
non mais j'ai deux enfants je vous jure
on utilisait à l'e3 par parent peut être
ce budget c'est une cinquantaine de
pages publié chaque semaine sans aucune
photo
[Musique]
c'est leurs loisirs leur télévision
parce qu'ils n'ont pas accès aux choses
modernes c'est un peu leur fils
comme ça ils peuvent apprendre ce qu'il
se passe dans la communauté se divertir
et quand même être informé c'est vrai
que c'est long vie qui fait la rigueur
qu'on fait voilà et moi je suis un combo
se trouve je tombais recrutement amour
du théâtre et du cinéma ont dû de l'atc
pas du tout à la creuse la télé oui je
peux pas de calais je passe plus gris
noir
mahdaoui avait pas eu
ces militants quelle lettre de
l'alphabet se prononce comme une
infusion
lâche le ténor alors le h
c'est comme une infusion mais c'est
quand même
merci très dérision ses amis on passe un
bon moment c'est vrai
merci beaucoup vous n'avez pas un style
g à jour votre programme avec super
smart